Thanks,
thanks.
Thanks
Dan.
Thank
you.
Where
you're not attempting to
actually communicate to
super position in what's essentially a
dominance hierarchy and using your verbal
techniques in order to
give me some temporary from
an intellectual perspective
and I think there's a
place for that sort of thing.
Awesome.
Although it pales in comparison to
the utility of a genuine conversation,
you know,
and I was asked today or times
correspondent part from
you today and asking you
about conversational style.
No.
One of the things that I've mentioned to
her voice that I would have rather have
the conversation with Kathy
Newman be a genuine conversation,
did not contest with a victory.
Even though I was fortunate enough in
that circumstance I would say to come up
with that doesn't mean the way that
when quest for the best I can have
collateral effects.
You're just like having a
reciprocal theater council.
My car that were very positive,
but it would've been a lot better.
I would think it would have been a much
better indicator of the health of our
culture.
If we could have just had an intelligent
discussion about what was the.
We were talking about extending something
that resembled hand to hand combat,
you know,
in a very modified form on television.
I think that one of the reasons
that the neuron online media,
our classroom incredible rapidity is
because much of our public dialogue has
degenerated into dominance hierarchy
conversation where one person up and gabby
three eight perspective is correct.
You know the problem with
demonstrating that your eight,
your eight perspectives threat
isn't what the hell you know.
You know,
we just don't run into
anyone ever who sold wise,
been deployed is absolutely
everything they open could be,
you know,
it only takes seconds of self reflection.
I understand that there's
a lot you don't know,
which is really cool because what you
know is insufficient to provide me with
everything you need.
And so the fact that there's a
lot more that you don't know,
it was about the most helpful thing you
can possibly imagine because there's
always the possibility that you might
learn something that you really need to
know and there's always the possibility
that the person that you're talking to,
even if you disagree with them or maybe
even because you disagree with them.
My the key to something that
you agree to meet John Hall.
You know what?
I've learned this.
I'm going to tell you a
story about Carl Rogers.
I recommending books by
women had one called on me.
For example,
Roger,
you know,
handful of cameras.
So clinicians from the 20th century were
pretty outstanding teachers in regular
thing.
I to say is not the speed useful.
You know,
when these people usually put in 25,000,
30,000,
50,000 hours of intense conversation with
people who were really in trouble most
of the time to go see a
clinical psychologist,
to be doing things that have gone astray
in some ways that you can imagine.
Some of the conversations that you have
with the psychotherapist are generally
extremely serious.
Have endless opportunity to engage in
complex discussions with people who were
trying to solve extraordinary
difficult problems,
and one of the things I
liked about Roger says he,
he sort of formalized the idea,
Freud,
Freud in some sense invented the idea
that conversation could be curative,
but he never really thought about,
but as the conversation
itself being curative,
he thought about it as the revelation
of secrets that were toxic.
It's something like that.
So if you had an extremely negative
experience sometime in your life,
joy,
it would be useful for you
from an emotional perspective
to be able to express
that emotion at that
women faculty curator.
That actually seems to be wrong.
Sometimes great thinkers are growing
and productive and interest in waves.
So Freud was right,
that careful conversation
that could be curative,
but he was wrong about the mechanisms.
It doesn't the expression of
emotion that appears to be curative.
It's the articulation of the
situation and the analysis of it.
So then you understand why it happened
so that you don't do it again or so that
it doesn't happen to you again.
National expert.
The purpose of memory.
You think,
well,
the purpose of memories to
remember the past and that's wrong,
the grinch,
if you don't do the same damn stupid
thing over and over again so your mind
isn't satisfied with his representation
of the negative event until you've
analyzed of so you can find
out why put in that situation,
even if you're the anxiety,
your
or someone else,
they want to know exactly why it happened
and then they want you to come up with
a strategy so it doesn't happen again,
and so that's the real secret to the
curator power of therapeutic conversation.
It's something that's worth doing just
in your day to day life when you're
talking to people because if someone has
something that's troublesome that they
need to relate to you free of what
they're trying to do is articulate out the
causal sequence that led to
negative consequences and
to come up with a strategy
for avoiding that in the future.
Patient listening can really
help them through that.
Generally,
if you're a therapist,
mostly what you do is listen.
You know what you find,
and this is something brought
yourself outlined quite carefully.
You find that if you ask people,
they will tell you what's
wrong in their life.
They're figuring out what
they don't want them.
They'll think through and
can think through solutions
and your job is to listen
so they can most people think by
talking and maybe to ask questions of
clarification.
So of my clients are talking to me.
Um,
and what I'll do is I sit and listen.
It's sort of a meditative state or not
trying to impose a few point part of it
because I don't want to write like,
I don't know what your
throne will be as you know,
but whatever it is,
it's not my problem they have and I
don't necessarily know what the solution
should be for you.
And so I'd be very hesitant,
hesitant to even suggest that
it might be because you know,
you're your own particular being.
Your solution isn't going to be.
I get to public line.
And then if you asked just no,
I never questioned why people are
anxious that just makes sense,
are anxious all the time
and it's the same pain.
It's like you're in pain.
It's unsurprising.
It's like life is pain,
pain,
that's the real miracle.
You should be on your piece about that
because it's not gonna last very long.
So Roger's idea is this,
he said a couple of things.
So the first thing is if you're
going to have a conversation,
you have to decide that you want
things to be better rather than worse.
And so that's,
that's hard because you know what it's
like when you're angry with someone you
might be willing to take a couple of
blows to the head if you could just punch
them four or five times more and so you
know you're willing to take a fair bit
of pain if you can
inflict even more knots.
And so that's something we probably want
to see if you can overcome right at the
beginning.
I think,
well I get irritated at you and I can
think of all the things I'd like to
reflect some pain,
but maybe I can regulate itself like
intelligent person work for the student to
be better.
So that's the first thing you phone and
I think that's part of the commitment of
marriage or a relationship
or marriage in particular.
It's one of the things that you sort of
square onto Indians that you're actually
going to try and make things
better for each other.
And for yourselves as a cop that's.
And you know,
we fall short of that because people
aren't paying any stretch of the
imagination.
Perfect.
But this is what you're hoping for her.
It's like,
why else would you ever bought it with it?
You know,
it's just a hopeless costs
right from the beginning.
You're in before you got to Orient
yourself to try to make things better.
Then the other person mastery pain
because one of the things Roger says,
apart from the fact that you're going
to get dr whatever the problems happened
to be,
perhaps as the perpetrator,
which is a big problem,
then you're gonna have to come down
with yourself ethically and all of that,
which is unbelievably annoying
and difficult because you
will like what you find
most of the time.
So.
But you also have to be patient.
But the first one or three of sort
of landscape of trouble and pain,
and they're going to do that badly and
stupidly in they never take manner.
Maybe you want to help them with that.
You know,
like you know what are the things
that you might want to think too,
especially if you're the person who wins
the arguments is that maybe you don't
want them to do so.
Maybe you want to to formulate the
arguments even more powerfully so that you
configure that you can help them solve
it so that you don't have to be the
stupid winter all the time because
it's not a good longterm solution.
So now it's a funny thing because you
don't generally think or maybe it would be
a good idea to help your opponent make
even better arguments that they make.
But if you have to be married to them
or if they're a close knit part of your
immediate community,
that that's exactly what you want to do.
So Rogers would say,
well,
you listen to the person and he
asked questions of clarification.
You Orient Yourself so that you're
willing to change if necessary,
because Roger's also pointed out that
one of the impediments to listening is
courage because people will tell you
things that will require change on your
part that's destabilizing and unsettling
and required to soul search if you
don't want that.
So it requires courage to to actually
listen and it requires courage to try to
make things better.
So let's say you have in place,
he asked questions and
clarification and see.
One of the things,
again,
I'll refer to that Kathy Newman,
a interview.
What you kept saying to me was so new.
You're saying so what you're saying was,
and then she would provide a summary
of what I was hypothetically say,
which had absolutely nothing
to do with what I say.
So I mean African striking the
evidence to me very rapidly,
but I think to everyone who watched
the interview as it progressed,
what you're supposed to do to say,
okay,
well here's what I think you said and
you don't want to be a smart ass about.
You don't want a strong man,
your opponent because then you're in
the position of like trivial victor,
you know,
if I listened to you
when you say something,
even if it's not that love formulated and
parody of and satirize it feeding back
to you.
It's like it's demonstration.
Maybe by momentary
intellectual superiority,
but probably not,
but it's not helping with
the damn conversation call.
What Roger was recommended was then you
restate what the person said that to
them in terms they agree with and so
sometimes that means to do make your
argument for them better
than they needed themselves.
That's actually an indication that you're
really listening so the person lays
out their problem,
whatever it happens to be,
and you say,
okay,
as far as I can tell,
here's what you meant,
and the second rule for
the Rogerian dynamic and
conversation was the person who
has to agree with you summary,
and so that's real stringent task,
right?
Especially if someone is criticizing you.
It's like,
okay,
I'm listening to the damn criticism.
It's like,
I'm not going to just roll
over and agree with it,
but I'm going to listen to it,
so then you tell me what your
problem is with me and I think,
okay,
as far as I can tell,
this is what you think the
problem is and if you agree,
it's like,
well then I was listening.
Well then what are the
things Roger's pointed out?
They're not?
Which is true,
but law actually like it's true.
If you interact with someone and
you're not acting like that's true,
they're not going to be happy with you
because if I interact with you like
you're not valuable,
we're not going to have a
very pleasant conversation.
It certainly not going to be the
grounds for any continuing relationship,
so we definitely treat each other when
we're treating each other like it works.
We treat each other like we have a spark
of divinity within us and it's at the
core of our law,
so it's like all so always the possibility
that it's true possible in what's the
alternative that we have
no value whatsoever.
No transcendent value whatsoever.
At least we're conscious beings that
confront reality and give it shape.
That's something.
It's not trivial
so well with speed.
Well birthday,
fake her up one day.
Now you want.
You want more misery.
There's enough damage.
Misery as far as I can tell,
right?
So maybe lead actually
broadened my misery in the
evening.
The family bringing ecosystem
is a visit that's back,
but evil is the breeding of misery into
existence for the sake of the mission
and you don't get that.
Then you have thought about
yourself very much at all,
all the time.
Try and make it worse than they have to
be delighted in the faculty naturally,
even if it's directed
towards himself that time,
she might just start by doing that,
like just decided,
well,
I'll try to purposely make things worse.
How would that be?
Well,
you can run it as an experiment.
You might think,
well,
what if you turned down
for three or four years,
so I cannot really do anything
that makes things worse.
Well,
how much better would it be?
And that's just kind of
didn't really do nothing.
It wasn't that good motto,
do no evil,
and they dropped that back.
I noticed
finger on what you want,
so here's something to want.
There's this philosopher named Emmanuel,
the end of this idea for like an epic,
and he said,
don't do anything that you would want
to be expressed as a general universal
rule.
So you're gonna make a decision.
You think,
okay,
well this is the decision that
everyone would make everywhere.
How would that work out?
That's a good way of judging whether
or not your decision is acceptable
day.
Let's say you want things to be good.
That's good.
Okay,
so let's think about what good means.
Well,
certainly it means an
absence of stupid software.
We can all agree on that.
So less offering it would be good.
We can start fast like,
well,
there's positive of goods that you can
only vision and so we won't reciprocity
in human history.
I think it's partly because
there's so many items,
right?
The step of building that
will be 9 million before
population starts to decline.
That'll happen about 30 years,
so we can probably manage that.
Right?
We've probably managed building.
It doesn't look like we're going to
overpopulate the planet and but also looks
to me like we could
have anything we wanted.
No Gates,
Bill Gates,
you fingers.
You can get rid of the five
most significant transmissible
diseases in the next
20 years.
We have the rate of poverty in
the world from the year 2000 2012.
We're hoping about 300,000 people a
day with the power grid right now.
Like obesity is a bigger problem
than starvation by a huge margin.
So I can.
There's the devil victory for you.
So you know,
and of course there's a million
insane genius silicon valley who are,
who are coming up things so fast
that they can't even keep track.
We're going to have intelligent
machines in no time flat.
So we've got to decide.
You might think,
well,
maybe it's time for us collectively and
I truly believe is the case to be the
face of what we want
and why not?
We're all British know certain people
are Richard and other people definitely
were Richard than in any human beings
have ever been in the entire history of
the
opportunity.
In front of us,
we can make of that what they wanted,
but we have to be discipled.
We'd have to sharpen yourself openness
and determine whether we want to recreate
the hell of the 20th century to do at
the drop of a hat or whether we want to
bring something new and remarkable being
I would say the way we're going to do
that isn't really even by
collective decision making,
perhaps not even by policy,
but by because no,
nobody knows what's coming.
Right?
Things are coming down so fast
but don't know what it is.
It's like so what do you do when things
are coming at you so fast that you can
prepare and that's risk.
Get to get ready so that you can.
You can contend with whatever comes your
way and you do that by straightening
your cell phone and God
only knows I was straight.
We get and so and you don't have anything
better to do than to try and trying to
justify as the suffering of life
and stops you from being bitter.
So what's the downside to that?
Adopt the responsibility.
That's it,
but the responsibilities,
the meaning in life,
it's like,
well,
that's not so bad.
Is it a responsibility or an opportunity?
It's a responsibility.
If someone forces and dawn,
you know,
opportunity if you decide
to do it voluntarily,
so
it's a nice place to stop.
Thank you.